[Music]
ah
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
thank you for being here good night
that was absolutely amazing
who do they think i am
they know who you are
andy back me up on this we've been doing
this it's been 20 years i don't think
i've seen a reaction like that that is
absolutely incredible
andy yes hello
is that true it's true yeah people
really seem to like you yeah
[Applause]
thank you yeah
it's you and al roker the only two that
actually
[Applause]
get that intensity of of love and
affection how are you you look fantastic
you always look good
i i thank you very much i feel fine yeah
you feel good
you're rubbing the chair a
lot let's talk
good you're just shocked about me
no this is all about you what are we
going to talk about me no one wants to
hear about me we want to hear about you
you just shot the sequel to anchorman
and everyone wants to know how was it
i don't
i don't have anything in life experience
to compare it with so
i wouldn't i wouldn't be able to tell
you what it was really like i went there
i was there for a day i did some stuff
that i'm not so sure about
not sure what you did
and it was nothing like i've ever
been part of before
and and i uh left
[Laughter]
and uh i had not seen anchorman you
hadn't seen the first anchorman
no oh so you didn't know what you were
in for i had no idea
you thought this was a serious movie
about anchorman
you showed up you had no idea
i knew it was a
comedy
but i didn't know what kind of comment
[Laughter]
how was how was will ferrell
uh he's insane yeah yes he is he's
insane everybody that works there is
really
insane yeah
and they don't care about anything yes
yeah
except uh um
the joke yeah yeah
but i don't know what the joke is and
maybe
i can't wait to see you in the movie now
cause you're just gonna wander in
look around and then wander off camera
that's what's going to happen
i think it can be cut that way
you know it's funny i got to bring this
up at one point uh i want i don't know
how long ago this was but i'm going to
assume this was the late 80s maybe you
had your own ron burgundy look going
what's we found this still
[Applause]
[Music]
that was a fantastic
that's when he was glenn fry's food
taster
that's fantastic